welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the biggest
rick head on youtube and this is the
channel where me seeks
out all the easter eggs and hidden
details in rick and morty
episode five of season 5 is now out and
throughout this video we're going to be
raising hell with our hell raising dudes
night out
the entry is called a morty can griffiti
which is a play on the film american
graffiti directed by george lucas
starring harrison ford this movie came
out four years before the pair worked on
star wars together
and it has a lot of things in common
with the episode that we see
the movie takes place in 1962 and it
chronicles the last night of a group
before they begin their lives as
grown-ups
this sort of mirrors what we see as it's
a night out with rick and jerry
alongside some devilish friends now
there's a lot of occult
and significant imagery throughout the
episode after opening on a shot of
rick's ship parked at the drive and
beth's car in front of the house
we cut to the inside to see rick and
jerry getting ready for the night out
beth asks jerry if he can look after the
kids as someone's played barry white
over the racetrack speakers
and now there's a seven horse pregnancy
there are actually 14 horses typically
in a race
so seven of them got pregnant whilst the
other seven were the ones
making them pregnant i'm not gonna
explain the birds and the bees to you
though
now barry white was also a soul singer
known for making music that people
smashed to
more times than you should smash that
like button reckon packs a box of occult
items and these include a three-eyed
skull and are missing a finger
and a pyramid with a face on it the
first is a reference to the third eye
which is typically thought to be found
if someone has psychic abilities
beyond that this also has links to
hinduism namely the third eye of shiva
and a skull with one was even uncovered
in a hindu temple
near madurai the ancient one also
touched the position of dr strange's
third eye in his solo film before he was
sent through the multiverse
and this idea of a third eye has a lot
of ties with religion
and spirituality the second two items
i'm not 100 sure on
but i think the first may be a nod to
either a monkey's paw
or potentially the hand of glory the
latter
may be a nod to the all-seeing eye which
we've seen take a lot more prevalence
with conspiracy theories
surrounding the illuminati like i said
i'm not 100 sure on them so let me know
below what they pull from if you know
cheers there's also a skin goblet which
typically in witchcraft are used to
drink blood from
rick says he likes jerry but as we learn
he knows he's lame
and he's just taking him out with demon
spawn because they enjoy suffering
summer is put in charge of babysitting
morty and though she's initially against
him bringing people over
she changes her mind when she learns
that it's gonna be bruce chug back
i was wondering if that might be tied in
with the chude from last week
but as we learn there's no relation
because should
and the word shut unconnected and i'm a
[ __ ]
now bruce has just transferred from
another school and they both have to win
him over before he learns how lame they
are
cheetah morty being a grandpa's boy and
some are shampooing her pubes
she farts in his face and calls him a
sexist if he doesn't like it
and yeah this is this is kind of the
juvenile humor that i've come to expect
from rick and morty
now rick and jerry warp using the portal
gun which was thought to be missing from
this season
a lot of people suspected that this
confirmed the families we were following
were all decoys as we learned decoys
weren't allowed to travel into space
and because of the missing portal gun in
the other four episodes
many thought that every single family
had just been a copy
now this at least confirms that this is
the real rick and morty
and it's a nice little addition to the
episode using a hell cube they summon in
some demons that are clearly playing on
the cenobites from the film series
hellraiser
led by pinhead these monstrous creatures
were called for through correctly
aligning a puzzle box
and they saw after delights that
involved removing the skin from people
and torturing them by playing the most
boring breakdowns on youtube
so thanks for the views guys now there
were lots of pins and needles
as well as skin being pulled back
throughout those films
and the monsters are clearly based on
them we learned that jerry has planned
for some jareoki at the bar phantasma
which is actually spanish for ghost
turns out that rick has been doing this
every friday after selling them some
faulty skin hooks
and they head inside after hearing they
have the entire smash mouth catalogue
who you may know for their song rock
star hey now if you're enjoying this
video
we we'd also massively appreciate the
thumbs up and hit the subscribe button
as we are doing weekly videos on the
show
and you definitely want to be around
here for the crap puns and even
crappervids
which means they're good
now after the title screen we cut to
bruce chuppan sorry
bruce shut back arriving to his own
theme song
and his pros include that he hasn't done
anything embarrassing yet
and that he also has no credit which is
perfect credit
morty plays some interdimensional cable
and we can see that on the screen is the
website for story train
which first appeared in the episode
never ending morty
conducted by storylord the train can
pass through different stories in space
and it's popped up from time to time in
the series they then watch olympic
diving with bad swimmers which has
divers who can't swim pulling off high
level jumps
now i love it where they just do stupid
stuff like this and hopefully we can get
an interdimensional cable episode this
season
at some point realizing that chirp back
is playing things close to the chest
they decide to touch rick's stuff but
before doing this a password protected
hologram appears
and says which is of course a call back
to jurassic park when dennis and edre
said the same thing
bruce goes outside to see rick's ship up
close and this gets a big character rock
in this episode in which the sentient
ride becomes
good friends with morty and summer on it
we can see the bumper stickers which say
i penis symbol schliemmys which we
learned in interdimensional cable 2
were used to make plumbus there's also
one for glotto 86b
but i can't remember for the life of me
exactly what this is
or if it's even been in the show years
of filling my head with marvel stuff
has rendered me useless and i apologize
anyway bruce says it's like a spaceship
made of garbage
and this is literally the case as the
lighter just torches taped down
and even the engines are made of trash
cans summer tries to get in but the
defense system kicks up
which morty tries to disable by saying
defense systems offline
the ship makes a very snarky remark over
this as it wouldn't be very secure
i think it might be a nod to batman
forever namely when riddler broke into
the bat cave and the defense system
started up all the computers
and brought the batmobile up even though
there was an intruder
hey maybe maybe it's not all useless
marvel knowledge hey and and there's
some useless dc knowledge in there too
now summer brings up the keep summer
safe episode in which he was stuck
inside the ship
whilst rick went out to do stuff due to
the defense system she started a war
and it's a nice little call back to that
episode we then see the postbox bit from
the intro
play out in which summer smashes some
sentient ones with a baseball bat
they also travel through a black hole
which i think is meant to mimic what
happens in guardians of the galaxy vol
2 when the characters go through too
many warp points
over the top of this beth goes to the
bar and we see jerry singing the song oh
yeah by yellow
which you might know from ferris
bueller's day off in here we can see
they also sell ip ape
which is a play on ipa and foamies which
rick drank at the start of the planet
episode
bear tells the cenobytes exactly what
she thinks of them
but she ends up joining them on their
wild night out
now dan horman said that the entire
episode started with a sort of
dinner for schmuck's angle where there
was someone you loved but
they were so cringy that it pretty much
takes over the entire night
this is reflected in both groups while
having their own nights of trying to
save embarrassment
and it makes for quite a fun episode in
my opinion
now in space the group fly amongst an
asteroid belt
and race what i want to say is a scrotum
pod racer
i don't know but the engines pretty much
look like that and even the pilot looks
like he has balls for a face
now it turns out that the ship has been
recording their entire night so that it
can blackmail them
and we see a moment in which morty
urinated against the windshield
this is now her joyride and she flies
through space pulling an entire solar
system behind her
which draws the attention of a
galactus-esque planet eater
in case you don't know who this is it's
basically a marvel character that flies
through space devouring planets
and he's one of the most fearsome
villains in the comics
maybe it is all useless marvel knowledge
now moving on
the ship also makes short work of him
and they travel to a drive-in in which
we see a robot waitress
that i think might be based on rosie
from the jetsons
a change morpher bangs into the ship and
the pair start flirting but the ladder
initially pulls out all of her weapons
which are exactly the same as the ones
we saw on display in the aforementioned
summer episode
the change morpher is obviously based on
transformers
but instead of an autobot or decepticon
hand symbol
they have one on them which typically
means hang loose also i forgot to
mention
that shut is slang for a vagina anyway
they decide to help her lose her
virginity
and morty slips it in and he's had sex
with his doorknob
back at fantasma beth tells the story of
the time that jerry crapped his pants
after eating too much soup
and he says that he did this soup
because the soup was warm and it was
cold which yeah
makes sense i guess now he also says my
wife
which is calling back to the borah
impression everyone used to do in the
naughties
but he's still doing because he's a
loser
know who else is a loser my wife i
got you sucker now in the bathroom jerry
over here's the hell spawns slagging him
off
and in here we can see graffiti that
says the flesh curtains rule which has
been scribbled out to say
really suck i'm guessing that one of
them wrote this and the vandalism caused
pain to someone which gave them pleasure
but then they also wrote really suck
over it which gave them pain
which in turn gave them pleasure try
trying to figure that all out but
there's also a mutang one which is an
american mustad
however it is riffing on the rap group
the wu tang clan
we also see one for beryllium zeppelin
which is of course a play on led
zeppelin
beryllium was actually used to make
zeppelins whereas lead meant that they
would go
down and give people a quick stairway to
heaven hey
having that now they call jerry a moon
calf which
basically means a foolish [ __ ]
elsewhere we watch the ship disguised as
a change morpher
trying to lose that v card but after
she's exposed
she ends up murdering everyone and they
go on the run after ruining the night by
bobbing them out the fleshlings decide
to make their own fun
and they too kill everyone in the ball
and take jerry to hell
this mirrors the trio being chased by
the police and rick and beth wear s
m clothes and travel to the underworld i
love how most of the dialogue here is
based around things being painful
which gives those in hell pleasure and
there's some hilarious back and forth
between all the characters
turns out they wanted them to come down
there so that they could come
down there and yeah i think the double
speak going on just makes the scene so
bad
and yet so good rick refers to it as
adam's family bs at one point
and they of course took pleasure from
the bad things in life
morty summer and bruce get assigned a
public defender who they say is alison
hannigan
but no relation the ship has shoved a
chip in the back of her head to control
her and she wants them to pin it and
shut back but they say it's not his
fault and that they just projected their
insecurities onto him
this is of course reflected in the ship
who then drops plan b which is a
jailbreak
and she completely destroys the prison
whilst rick launches his own escape plan
to kill the demons with genuine
sincerity
rick admits he loves jerry and this
powers up the weapon
which allows them to wipe out the
cenobites including one who has mouse
traps clamping down on his nipples
the ship makes it back home and washes
the smell of adventure off itself
which rick almost becomes aware of but
jerry farts and takes the blame for it
back in the house everyone gets to keep
what happens secret but church says he
can't decide whether summer and morty
are lame
and he says that he needs to feel it out
at school had he stayed with them he
would have had some friends but instead
he tries to hang out with the cool kids
namely trisha who judge him for wearing
the same pants two days in a row
morty and are summerstown at the back
staring at his humiliation
and they call him bruce chutpants
because high school is rough
chuck's deposing the song at the star
that introduced him he gets one calling
him his nickname
and he walks home to get beaten by the
post boxes whose summer of course
attacked earlier in the episode
that wraps it all up and i'm sure
there's some easter eggs in there that i
missed
so definitely let me know below if you
spotted any
now as for my thoughts on the episode i
thought it was way better than last week
i know some people out there thought
that that was the worst one they'd ever
made
and even the creative team at the end
said they pretty much phoned it in
i didn't think it was that bad but i
didn't think it was anything amazing
either
however this felt a lot more in line
with the kind of thing i want to see in
rick and morty
and i had a lot of fun with it i love or
just in general i just love
references to horror stuff and when the
show goes off into an occult direction
especially at jerry's expense i really
have fun with it
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on it so make sure you leave
them below and as a thank you you'll be
entered into a competition where we're
giving away three mcu box sets on the
30th of july
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the episode
we picked the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one
on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the last episode of loki which
will be linked on screen right now we've
gone over all the easter eggs and
pointed out some of the cool dl's in it
so it's definitely worth watching if you
want to know more without the way
thank you for seeing through the video
i've been poor i'll see you next time
take care peace